i think we have a lot of preconceptions
about what race really is
what is race has changed dramatically
through time
there is no official scientific
definition of race
we're all different
[Music]
i was aware that i wasn't white the
teacher
said no no tess is something else and
everybody's eyes are on me and i'm a
really shy person
she said but what are you tessa
a lot of people imagine that there is
some biological tangibility to race
because
we use it so much
race really is a social construct but
just because something is a social
construct that doesn't mean it doesn't
have meaning in people's lives like
money
or the nation-state or democracy or all
these other things
that define how we live but are also
constructed it influences what you're
eating
it influences the type of healthcare you
have access to the type of school you
have access to
how people feel about you and it's a
powerful marker for all of these things
that we care about when we're trying to
run a society
race has never been something that i
don't have to think about
it's put onto us when you look at the
history and origins of this idea you
start to see it for what it really is
which is
the manifestation of power
[Music]
people imagine that people have always
thought about skin color in this
racialized way
and we really haven't that idea is no
more than a few hundred years old
it's not really until the age of
colonialism
in the 17th century that you start
getting the idea
that each continent has its own
individual kind of people it arose in a
very specific
moment in history in the 17th century
you're taking long trips
by ship and you're struck by how
different people
look than you remember them when you got
on
so this is the first edition of sistema
nature so the systems of nature
and for man lineus distinguishes
four varieties these varieties
correspond to the four
continents where it really changes
is in the 10th edition of sistema nature
this is the foundation of scientific
racism
he brings in moral character so the
american is
red and choleric and stands up straight
the european white sanguine and
muscular the asian sallow melancholic
and stiff
and finally the african black phlegmatic
and lazy so these stereotypes have
endured
through the ages
[Music]
if you're going to take a group of
people and you're going to decide that
they're not people anymore
then you need something to justify that
you can be defined very differently
depending on the country that you're in
or the time that you're in
and that's how these categories have
always been used they are political
tools
that change depending on
their usefulness to whoever is doing the
[Music]
categorization
[Music]
[Music]
we are one of the most homogeneous
species on the planet humans have far
less genetic variation
than chimpanzees do and yet those
chimpanzees look the same to me
there were never any pure races there is
no gene
that exists in all the members of one
race and not another
there is no black gene there is no white
gene human groups overlap completely
in their genetic variation
in the same way that you're related to
your family you can get a kind of fuzzy
genetic similarity
but when you get to the continental
level which is really where we're
talking about race
that genetic similarity is so fuzzy and
so statistically weak as to be
almost meaningless we have this envy of
fields where things are hypeler
simplistic
we want to be able to look at a genome
and say that people are these kind of
concrete
immutable things that cannot be changed
genetics doesn't work that way it's the
product of many genes interacting with
each other and their environments
to fully answer the question about what
a living thing
is it's going to be about much more than
gene
if i were to go out onto the street
today and find someone of indian
heritage like myself
and randomly then pick someone who is
not of indian heritage
it is perfectly statistically possible
for my genome to have more in common
with that person who isn't of indian
heritage
than that person who is
[Music]
even though race itself is a construct
racism is real and we are not
in a post-racial society race keeps
making itself and power keeps making
race
even though we know that race isn't
biological
we've been living with this idea of it
being
real for so long that it means that
people who do have a shared
racial identity have now cultural
similarities
which has been born out of hardship
but it's still beautiful and important
the biology of race is not a useful
concept
i have a different historical trajectory
i love the african-american tradition
but it's not better than anybody else's
it's just the one that i'm a part of i
don't think we're gonna stop
classifying people because i think
that's how we make sense of the world
i think every generation is going to
classify
people according to the criteria that
are politically important
to i don't think we need to find new
boxes to put people in
i think we now have the opportunity to
say we understand that all of these
things are a spectrum in a way that we
hadn't considered before
so instead of finding new ways to
categorize people we can just find new
ways to exist
better together race is a story
that's handed down and handed around
we can choose the stories that we tell
thanks for watching
if you enjoyed that be sure to check out
these videos next and if you haven't
already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video